quelles sont les revendications
territoriales des autochtones au québec
oui bienvenue à paroles autochtone cette
semaine je réponde à la question de
claude qui est encore une fois une bonne
question avec beaucoup de détails qui
serait distribué entrer dans des grandes
grandes grandes description mais je
pense qu'il ya certaines des
revendications territoriales qui ne sont
pas uniquement liées au territoire faut
jamais oublier que la propriété du
territoire telle qu'elle est conçue en
amérique du nord est pas exactement
celle que l'on défend nous du côté des
premières nations donc dans des
revendications territoriales ça va
parler de territoires mais
d'accessibilité aux territoires de
protection du territoire on va parler
aussi d'accessibilité aux ressources du
territoire donc le saumon le caribou le
régnard et avec ses revendications
territoriales viennent les
responsabilités donc c'est pour ça qu'on
voit en parler beaucoup plus du point de
vue de gestion du territoire plutôt que
de possession du territoire
malheureusement quand on parle en fait
d'aider des rencontres avec des
gouvernements qui sont eux occidentaux
il faut souvent qu'on parle de propriété
du territoire et là ça va être souvent
les ressources la coupe forestière
l'hydroélectricité alors c'est très
difficile d'avoir des fois des
conversations à ces deux niveaux le
parce qu'on parle de deux choses
différentes dans la même langue mais
avec des concepts complètement différent
donc ce serait très compliqué d'aller
dans chacune des communautés pour parler
de revendications territoriales parce
que chaque communauté a des
revendications très spécifiques
certaines revendications vont être tenus
en tant que ea nous par exemple la
nation présentement veut défendre la
protection du caribou ou je pense aussi
les algonquins les attikameks et encore
une fois les inouk on pense à protéger
le territoire quand il ya un passage de
deux pipelines de gaz naturel par
exemple qui va venir détruire territoire
comment est ce qu'on fait pour parler de
ces enjeux le quand on veut pas défendre
la même affaire et qu'on ne parle même
pas les mêmes concepts dont les
revendications territoriales sont
énormes et ils sont très distincts par
communauté est aussi tenue par nation
alors c'est pour ça que je pense
la première chose que tu préfères claude
s'est intéressé à la communauté la plus
proche de chez vous et voir quels sont
les enjeux territoriaux qui la touche et
à quel point est ce que vraiment ils
ressemblent souvent à sur des québécois
qui habite un territoire
présentement il ya encore beaucoup de
coalition discret très nouvellement
entre des communautés autochtones et non
autochtones pour créer des lieux qui
vont permettre à ces communautés l'un
des deux côtés de pouvoir jouir du
territoire et des ressources pour encore
les cette future génération parce que
venir de la ville puis aller chercher
des ressources souvenir d'un autre pays
vient les chercher des ressources sur un
territoire c'est facile mais quand tu
habites le territoire là ces
revendications ne sont pas uniquement
autochtones sont citoyennes donc c'est
pour ça qu'on voit ces coalitions le
secret sinon on pourrait passer la
journée juste a énuméré chacune des
communautés ce qui le demande pour
pouvoir avoir un meilleur aspect de
l'avenir et ce qui nous qui veut nous
pendre au nez dans le fond dans un
contexte de changement climatique
alors claude merci pour la question puis
jeu désolé si on a si peu tard pour une
question si énorme mais c'était pas à
nous envoyer des questions n'hésitez pas
à partager cette vidéo là et surtout
passé une belle semaine